the timing is suspect why would you drop
off those laptops a week before your
father announces his run for president
to call it careless is to barely scrape
the surface especially when you know
perfectly well what's on those laptops
not only this Treasure Trove of homemade
pornography which is like a Highly
Questionable Enterprise in and of itself
you have to wonder exactly what
motivates someone to continually film
himself engaging in sexual activity with
with all the various hookers that he was
consorting with in strippers and so
forth there's a vindictive carelessness
about it that's also Market because it's
not one laptop it's three and three is a
lot there's this immense amount of
detail about all of these business
enterprises that have been accumulating
for decades is he that addled that he
didn't even notice that this was foolish
or is there desire to be caught because
that's certainly a possibility or is
there revenge against his whole family
including his father I mean I I don't
know how to make heads or Tales of this
because it's so utterly preposterous